[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
seven cars and stuff spraying the one
day they look like me
dude he is the only thing it's
everything never had a girl screw you
out of a job I hate it no my mother used
to call me dangerous
I am dangerous come be men with it ah he
goes to 24 here we go
[Music]
brooch no no only through it
careful
[Music]
[Music]
all right it's ready you know
okay logos you look I'll read it on
[Music]
each and every one including Jerry
[Music]
just beyond that journey with the people
you love you've been acting so
suspicious of hours with dollars
this beautiful moment is upon us tonight
is that later fated made real
the fixation when I am your employer you
say you can be no porter kill you pull
that's all I know
is more in common with Hine Stein mozart
than he does with us the accountant the
client for some of the scariest people
on the planet to the secret this guy
have we have to go to the police please
can't protect you
we should go I need to know who he is
the accountant witted are
[Music]
Oh God
is he flying really messed up a blind
guy Edna who's there
stay right there come on
man I miss let me go
[Applause]
don't bring it up
nobody did what she did because you
cannot teach a cop to have you
but it will never come
the lobster
I can do that and one chip annotations
appear
[Music]
aha
mr. bear
serving water on
we hugged each other
Montand annually so function microwave
that I asked like it locked
UHF frequencies before we go on to the
stories I need to know more about you
I'm 29 years old
I work as a product contractor for the
NSA for the CIA I worked in various jobs
in the intelligence industry for last
nine years listen they're going to come
from and now that we've made contact
they're going to come for all of each
how about we just start with your name
okay
my name is Edward Joseph
[Music]
what was it you were doing doing
analysis for that stage for huh don't be
shy I don't want any minute the modern
battlefield is everywhere
how is this impossible I think of it as
a Google search except instead of
searching all in what could make public
we're also looking at everything they
don't I know about you the conversations
we've got there are they watching us
one man can stop the motor of the world
what was it about the job that makes it
more important in your life
no dan has been charged with espionage
you have no idea what it might be
accountable for other people's lives
are you going away chief even in the
country and I'm cooking I was over
[Applause]
haha
[Music]
god I am wrong every decision you can
talk on you come on tell me your best
but if you are I'm sorry we didn't call
from we're hiding out and after me
meet Mary Adam Pole oh I should have
known you'd bring a protege I'm under
the recipe though serious
how many years ago you're pretty
domesticated for Rasta and I can
anything
what does that mean you don't want
we were friends better than brothers
we fighting
just stop talking the world is not ready
your honor
what's the point it for in your life and
you you don't deserve either of them I
fall in love with every pretty things
you don't want to do this everyone
should see a cell point
she's the woman of the century
not when I've done the Big Bang okay
Association it's August critics wave
hell or high water is the best movie
I've seen to see no thanks loan the
least they could so they could swipe
your mom and Lance hanging back with our
money without any Texan I don't know
Eddie
looking brother I got a raise you
certain that Vegemite dish isn't justice
we're going on board yeah he's not a
crime
the good thing is though I'm not very
well hell or high water hood at all
the like city target 12 what are you
doing
waiting my twin brother who died here we
made this Oh whoever died first with any
other fine in the afterlife
you hear
[Music]
[Music]
Harrison took me Pablo Escobar in the
Medellin Cartel responsible for 80% of
the narcotics flooding into our country
major you're partying with the Brady law
let's get to it
that's one point six billion dollars
every month I'm an undercover federal
agent my mission is to infiltrate their
organization welcome to the United
States and take them down this is a
suicide mission
the infiltrators raided our delight your
team what are you doing out here start
you off your little honey
[Applause]
finally
Wow
welcome to Atlanta the frame to the air
to sweet are in theatres October 14th
any idea what could have any wire hey
you sure you didn't I got this you know
if you're interested I can talk to my
guys down the warehouse you think use a
hand for your thanks to Susan don't do
this any fun oh you guys are the best
thing in my life what pretty much the
only thing I haven't screwed up yet
I'm sorry yo you're you ever shot one of
these before
what took you boys out yes yes ah yeah
sure
illogical they gave us a card for
emergencies where our work
where's my phone spending time with you
I want to only get all the time
you drive need something and you can see
over the steering wheel
Wow the mom can't find out about this
no I don't think we go hang out anymore
oh that's kind of that
look burger a banana you all right you
know what he's doing
whoa so you don't air light in the
camera we were here first
isn't it that let me go no where is the
other day I'm your father my dad to
protect you
jumping country doesn't want to hear
71 figment that yet
don't keep you safe okay
you
to me my wife's anniversary TONIGHT a
really saving our butts here happy
anniversary
I don't know it's nice to meet your have
some beautiful hi
Jake's it's a fan of the new sitter hi
Jake hey be good you do what she says
never feel great living room work
someone we don't know we could you can
define alright sound together raised on
trophy overhead but not like your
victorious let's going to smash this on
top of here shall I stop smiling stop
smile
Oh
Oh Rome should be different
mom and dad say to violence on your pen
I'm hearing yeah
okay how about hide-and-seek 98 97 3 2 1
50 what's he doing here tonight I think
Greg deserves a special treat super one
now
sorry Soph don't be sorry
everyone died with them vomiting you
hear smile
sometimes it's okay to destroy things
for fun it's movie time is amazing I do
not like to hear one word about all the
games we've been playing there I've been
less you guys so far you haven't been
nice at all something is wrong she's not
beating up my sister I told you what
would happen if you miss an age
show me who are you
and
[Music]
in theaters and IMAX
you